[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
2016 won't be around for much longer but
you know what will be video games and
we've still got a whole month of them
before the new year here are the biggest
games dropping in the first week of
December after seven years in the making
we're finally getting the Last Guardian
this week team echoes latest outing
tells the story of a young boy in his
giant bird dog companion thing named
Treecko as they try to escape a giant
prison knowing Tamiko the game is going
to be packed with harrowing moments that
will make you very excited very happy or
very very sad you can start your journey
on ps4 on tuesday december six December
is a good time for horror right dead
rising for leans more toward action than
scares but it's still packed with
zombies crawling all over the willamette
mall Frank West is back just in time for
the holidays which means you'll be
raining hell on the undead with candy
cane launchers and killer food carts
this might be an older more grizzled
Frank than we're used to but his
adventure will still be full of fun
violent antics it all kicks off on Xbox
one and PC on the sixth oh you still
want more zombies well Arizona sunshine
has you covered put on your HTC vive or
oculus rift headset and you'll find
yourself smack in the middle of the
zombie apocalypse the immersion of the R
means you'll be battling these monsters
with realistic weapon handling
scavenging and survival fortunately the
hot stinky zombie breath doesn't quite
come through the headset you can take on
the end of the world alone or with
friends on the 6th if earth is overrun
with zombies you might as well head to
space with some new star wars
battlefront rug 1 dlc the movie isn't
here quite yet but the latest expansion
adds four new maps based on the planet
Scariff plus jenn-air so and orson
krenek as playable characters on top of
this the game is getting an x-wing VR
mission for free though you will need a
PS VR headset to experience it of course
this mission and the robe
DLC both launched on the 6th let's stay
in orbit just a bit longer with space
hulk deathwing this first-person shooter
is based on a strategy board game space
hulk which itself is based on Warhammer
40k so if you're a fan of the space
marines you'll probably have a great
time blasting away at stalkers and brood
lords with all sorts of guns and melee
weapons you can go it alone or as a
group of four and the campaign begins on
pc on December ninth and those are the
big new games will be playing this week
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with more games
next week
[Music]